what's one of the craziest things that
happened in that time that you spent
doing that where you kind of blew your
hair back and you're like whoa i wasn't
really expecting to see that happen
tonight i was down south and my buddy
and i were new to the scene and went out
to the bar after with these girls and
the girl i was going with she said she
broke up her boyfriend which he didn't
know they just broke up and another girl
was the bachelorette she was getting
married into well we're all walking to a
different part and uh the girl i'm with
her boyfriend comes picks her up i'm
like oh okay cool whatever hey i don't
want to step on anyone's toes my buddy's
like well i kind of go back to the hotel
and the
bride-to-be says well i'll come join you
guys and i'm thinking oh yeah yeah you
know guys and girls can be friends when
i believe that was a real thing
um so
we go back to the hotel and she's like
can i hang out in your room well they go
do their family yeah absolutely at this
point i see no problem right i have
platonic female friends i understand
that other people do so anyways